you could have seen this one coming dr.
Seuss is one of the world's most beloved
children's authors he's an American but
his books are written before 2008 so it
was inevitable that somebody in academia
was gonna call them racist and that of
course is exactly what happened the new
academic study argues that quote racism
spans across the entire Seuss collection
the move the study says it's a myth that
books like horton hears a who and the
Sneetches which are actually against
racism promote tolerance the chief
argument is that Seuss's characters are
to male and they've the wrong skin
colors whatever those are author and
columnist mark Stein joins us tonight
what they've the wrong skin colors what
would the skin tone is dr. Seuss that's
right they've done a survey and
concluded that only 2% of the characters
in dr. Seuss are persons of color and
they find this problematic I actually
find the word problematic problematic
because it's become a way of social
justice warriors to label anything they
don't like without actually engaging in
it without any coherent way and so it
may be there may be all kinds of reasons
why only 2% of characters in dr. Seuss a
persons of color there's not a lot of
same sex marriage in Jane Austen there
are very few Muslims in PG woodhouse
authors generally are entitled to write
about the characters they want to write
about if you talk with living novelists
for example the best-selling American
novelist Lionel Shriver told me last
year that because she writes about
characters who are not middle-aged white
women like herself
she gets accused of cultural
appropriation so if a white woman writes
in the voice of a black man she's
culturally appropriating if a thin
person writes in the voice of the obese
they're culturally appropriating so you
can't win either way
and what-what these vandals cultural
vandals are doing now basically trying
to make us live in a permanent year
zero as they called it in Cambodia where
we have no cultural inheritance and
we're just bobbing around in the flotsam
and the jetson of a hyper present tense
which is no way to live no art is being
created right now it's crap Oh literally
because it can't be okay I got to ask
you about this story I thought if you
didn't read this this morning said the
world's best bridge player apparently
he's got busted for doping his name is
Greg hey Guillermo he was suspended by
the world bridge Federation after a test
found elevated testosterone levels
bridge of course not typically
associated with home run records is this
are you surprised store there's doping
in bridge no absolutely not bridge is
renowned for the use of
performance-enhancing drugs all these
guy everybody's grandma is on steroids
and testosterone in the bridge falls
down at the Elks Lodge it's it's
terrible I can't III had a problem with
it too
I was playing solitaire with myself when
I realize I'd taken
performance-enhancing drugs you can't
you can't get through all these you go
to any Senior Center in Florida and
traces of urine are being found in there
drug samples all the time this is the
way this is this is just the world we
live in our performance-enhancing drugs
for bridge Falls it's it's we've come to
a bit that's why it's pouring across the
border yes because we have two anabolic
steroids in shuffleboard that's next I'm
totally kidding
mark Stein the best always great to see
you thank you thanks a lot Tucker